(upbeat music)
- When it comes to grilled cheese,
do you believe less is more,
or more is more?
Hi!
I'm Mimo.
I'm a Culinary Producer at Tasty.
Today, I'm going to test recipes
for a three-, six- and
12-ingredient grilled cheese.
May the best grilled cheese win.
First up, we're making our
three-ingredient grilled cheese.
For the first ingredient,
we are going to start with bread.
I decide to go with brioche,
because it's buttery and fluffy
with a hint of sweetness.
Our next ingredient is butter.
Everything is better with butter.
And since we only can
use three ingredients,
we want to make them count.
We are going to generously
butter one side of the bread
and place it on a hot skill.
And for our third and final ingredient,
we are adding sliced American cheese.
And we have picked American cheese
because it's such a classic.
Top the bread with three
slices of American cheese,
place the other slice of
bread on top, butter side up.
When the bottom slice of
bread is golden brown,
flip and continue cooking until
the other side has browned
and the cheese is fully melted.
And there we have it,
our classic three-ingredient
grilled cheese.
Bread, butter, cheese.
That really might be all you need.
I guess we will have to wait and see.
Next up, we have our
six-ingredient grilled cheese.
Our first two ingredients are
the same as our last version.
And those are bread and butter.
For this version,
we chose sourdough bread,
because we are looking
for a bread that's hearty
with a little bit of a tang.
After we spread the butter on one side
of each slice of bread,
we are going to place
them butter side down.
And now it's time to
introduce our new ingredients.
Ingredient number three is grated garlic.
I mean, think about it.
This is basically becoming a
garlic bread grilled cheese,
which sounds like a dream come true.
Ingredient number four is pesto.
We tried many different options
for seasonings and condiments,
but what we realized is
that pesto is the best way
to bring the flavor home.
Now, it's time for cheese.
We are going to pick two
different types of cheese,
mozzarella and sharp provolone.
We're using two types of cheese
because mozzarella is creamy,
while sharp provolone
will give our sandwich a nutty flavor.
And you're probably
noticing that these steps
are in a bit of a different
order than last time.
For the three-ingredient grilled cheese,
we just built the sandwich
right onto the skillet.
But because we have more
ingredients this time around,
we are building our entire sandwich first
to ensure even cooking throughout.
After cooking for about
five minutes on each side,
our sandwich is a beautiful golden brown
and our cheese is nice melted.
Time to eat.
Look at that ooey, gooey goodness.
Let's get started on the
12-ingredient grilled cheese.
Our first ingredient
is, of course, butter.
We're going to melt one
tablespoon of butter
in a small skillet.
Then add in a quarter cup
of sliced, yellow onions
and a pinch of salt.
Yep, I said onions!
Make sure to stir your onions often
until they are soft and
starting to caramelize.
Caramelizing onions usually
takes up to 40 minutes,
but since we're using
a very small quantity,
we're cutting ours back to 10 minutes.
Next, add in a generous
amount of brown sugar
and continue cooking the onions
until the sugar starts to caramelize.
Add balsamic glaze and stir.
By cooking these beautiful
caramelized onions,
we will add in some
sweetness to our final dish.
Next up, ingredient number six, thyme.
In a small pot,
combine the rest of your
butter and the thyme
to create a delicious infused butter.
This simple hack is going
to be a game changer.
We're going to brush our infused butter
into ingredient number seven, our bread.
For this recipe,
we went with artisanal country bread
with a thick crust and of course, texture.
This thyme-infused butter
will take our bread
to the next level.
That is why we're brushing a
generous amount on both sides.
Now, it's time to fry.
Everyone has their own
grilled cheese preference,
but I think we can all agree
that we want the bread to
be golden brown and crispy.
Now, we are going to start assembly.
This is definitely way more work
than the average grilled cheese,
but trust us,
the outcome will totally be worth it.
Ingredient number eight.
Coarse-ground Dijon mustard.
Spread the mustard evenly
on both slices of bread.
Next up, aged cheddar.
We're going to add the shredded cheese.
Next, ham.
This is not just a ham
and cheese sandwich.
This is an upgraded grilled cheese.
Our next cheese is Gruyere.
Gruyere is rich, creamy and salty,
while the aged cheddar is sharp.
On our other slice of bread,
add the caramelized onions.
Sandwich it up!
Before we throw this back on the heat,
let's sprinkle the pan with
our 12th and final ingredient,
Parmesan cheese.
We will then carefully
place our sandwich on top
of the Parmesan cheese.
While the Parmesan cheese
melts and crisps up
to create a crust,
we're going to top the
other side of our sandwich
with the rest of the Parmesan.
This is my favorite hack to
get our bread nice and crispy,
which will really make a
difference in the final sandwich.
Since both slices of bread
are a beautiful color
and our cheese is melted,
it's time to plate.
Here we have it.
Our 12-ingredient grilled cheese.
Not only do we have a
creamy, cheesy interior,
but we have a crispy Parmesan crust,
sweet caramelized onions
and a kick from the mustard.
And there we have it.
Our three-ingredient,
six-ingredient and
12-ingredient grilled cheese.
When picking my favorite
sandwich between the three,
I had to consider flavor,
texture and which sandwich
I would want to eat again.
I love how easy and classic
the three-ingredient grilled cheese is.
And the pesto and cheese combo
in the six-ingredient grilled
cheese tasted so great.
But, at the end of the day,
I keep going back for more bites
of the 12-ingredient grilled cheese.
Thanks for joining me
as I test our favorite three
grilled cheese sandwiches.
Let us know how you make
your favorite grilled cheese at home.
Bye!
(energetic music)